[Music]
so who amongst you plays video games
lawyers I expect way more hands to all a
bunch of liars so I have a Mac right the
Mac is all right
UNIX kind of system and all that the
thing that's not so great about a Mac is
you have to you know remind yourself of
most of the games can be played on
Windows what's actually kind of cool
nowadays though is you have these VMs
that you can spin up and these VMs you
know typically use them for deep
learning because it's a good GPU in it
but you can also use a GPU to play video
games
so there's this very cool service called
paper space and the idea with paper
space is they literally stream the
output of the video output to your
screen as if it's like a Netflix thing
the internet it's fast enough if you can
actually do this and my currently I'm
over the Wi-Fi over here and I cannot
send the right UDP packets so it's a
little bit slower but I found that it's
actually fast enough and I can do you
know head shots in Andromeda and I can
actually play video games over Wi-Fi
when I'm home on my couch and lately
I've been playing this video game that I
personally think is actually kind of
cool it's called divinity original sin 2
and I'm kind of a nerdy nerd and you
start playing a video game and you can
wonder can I use maybe Python to make me
better playing this video game so I
don't work for these people by the way
but super cool service if you want to
play video games and you own a Linux
computer or if you have an Android
device or if you've got a Mac that
Google parsec Google paper space and you
can play video games for forty Euro
cents an hour that's actually kind of a
good deal so okay I can play the video
game but now I have to play the video
game in a good way so what I'll be doing
now is I'll be reciting my findings and
you can find all the findings of my blog
called coning and the idea with the
video game is you kind of can make a
character like this this is the
character name of the character is
called the Red Prince I prefer to call
him big red and the idea of this
character just like most role-playing
games is you know you get this attribute
sheet and you can say hey I'm gonna put
more points and strengths and then the
guy gets more buff you could put more
stress points and intelligence and the
person gets more smart and depending on
how you want to make your character you
put points in different types of things
and in this case I just wanted this to
be like a super buff huge to run asaurus
so the idea is I want them to do a lot
of physical damage
so probably strength is good because
more strength means more points of
damage per attack and which is kind of
good because wits
does more critical damage so if you roll
a dice critical damage damage times to
the mechanics of the game work a bit
differently than this but this is sort
of the premise so that's great okay I
haven't talked about Python yet but what
you can do is you can sort of look
online and you can sort of look at the
formulas that you need to calculate this
and then you get to this conclusion like
hey I need to do calculus again
yes actually do the math right so you
have to say hey what's my expected
damage depending on how many points are
put in strength and how many points I
put in wits you have to do all this math
and the whole thing with modeling the
beginning is fun we were making the
model and the end bit is fun because you
actually get to make the conclusion but
it's all the math in the middle that's
kind of the boring stuff and there's a
great book about written about Python
called automate the boring stuff so
let's see if we can automate the boring
math with Python turns out you can
totally do this with a library called
simp I what's in PI does s y MP Y is
basically it allows you to do the math
so you didn't have to a my so you can I
think it's big enough that you guys can
actually read it so here's the sort of
the code that I've written for it
I said let's say I've got a total number
of points that's equal to a hundred I
had the Sun basically I can put it in
strength or I can put it in wits so s is
t minus W this is what was this again so
this is the probability that the
critical hit will occur which is which
divided by 100 again assume that is true
is from the video game and then the
damage that I will deal well that
depends on my score for strength and
then the expected damage that will do
that will keep in mind of the
probability for critical hit you can
make all these formulas you can get this
formula written just like this what you
can then do is you can evaluate e you
can actually see what comes out and what
the interpreter will then give you is a
formula with all the parameters that you
haven't defined yet all the maths and
you might say okay this is all kind of
nice but I don't like looking at this if
you actually run this in the ipython
notebook and you tell simp I to do
normal printing it will actually give
you the later
what you can then do is you can say hey
this expression it's all very well and
nice but please simplify it do the math
if I can clean it up a bit and I will
just go ahead and do that but you can
even then do is you can say you
differentiate yourself please with
regards to W and it will differentiate
on your behalf
remember this was super boring back in
college now you can sort of just
automate this what's even better is you
can say look even if if I have the
French hated this expression if you want
to take a maximum of it typical to do
you take differentiate set it equal to
zero so you can say hey here's an
expression that I have I want you to
solve it by changing this parameter and
it wants to be equal to zero boom that's
great I kind of can focus more on the
modeling and stuff I don't have to worry
so much about the maps because you know
Python while I'm at it for me so you can
do a second iteration on this because
before I did an iteration anyway I said
you know the top 100 I only have a
hundred points let's say that's now a
free parameter so I want to optimize for
s and W so independent of the total
number of points I know what the optimal
location is so you can differentiate for
W you can a friend shape for s and you
can combine everything so you get the
expression if I have an optimum what is
the solution and then we'll clearly say
the solution itself is an equation also
Simba is automating this for me so I
have a solution I can tell you what the
best score is all the math is great but
typically humans don't always like
looking at this so even though there's a
very nice exercise what I would
typically still advise you guys to do is
to make a very pretty plot where you can
do something like hey let's say this is
this is the number of points I put in
two widths according to the formula I
calculated before you know and you put
this in a report and all looks pretty um
please read the blog post if you're
actually interested in this because
there's actually a whole lot more that
symp I will do for you I've talked about
simple stuff here but what you can also
have happen is it can do integration for
you so anything with a log anything
that's kind of naughty
it'll integrate stuff for you as well
and you get the formula out there's even
some very cool probability theory stuff
where you can say hey this is a
probability distribution that's a
probability distribution if you had to
combine them in some sort of way let's
say you now know something so you can
actually do things like
give me the probability that y plus Z is
less than 3 given that zest is less than
2 it will just do all these calculations
for you so this is sort of getting
beyond the realm of curious fun and
actually touching on the realm of
actually slightly useful if you have a
proof and you don't understand it you
can check it in here and maybe it will
do it for you now there's an even lemma
checking so if you want to say hey this
is the variance and these are all
symbols please do the math for me such
that I know what the formula for the
math is for this expression you can even
do the riveted rule so you can declare
something to be a symbol or a function
and then you can say hey what's if I
differentiate F times G what do I get
out
it doesn't matter for you you can even
have the language be outputted so you
get code out then the pretty latex stuff
that I showed you another feature that I
really really like is the committers of
this package have recently put something
up so if you're if you're in some pie
and you say from simp I import this you
will get something called the Zen of
senpai it's all about the joy
unevaluated is better than evaluated the
user interface matters printing matters
and pure Python can be fast enough if
it's too slow it's probably your fault
documentation matters correctness is
more important than speed push it in now
and improve upon it later coverage by
testing matters smart tests are better
than random tests but random tests
sometimes find what smartest test is
missed the Python weighs probably right
the right way community is more
important than code now and this stage
of my five-minute talk I gather that you
guys think okay this was the peak moment
this is when FinCEN says that the Python
community is nice and great I'm going
and stuff further because you know this
is my blog so want people to see this so
what you then do is you post some reddit
now you can post this in two different
channels which I did I posted this in
the divine divinity like a video game
fan club Reddit and I post this in the
Python channel this happened like a week
ago I will quote you a comment from the
gamers spot at the noob I read this
article zero out of 10 it needs peer
reviewing and an extensive editing due
to grammar and
to sort of explain to you how well it
works this was a response within two
minutes the Python response was
fantastic right of man I had no clues to
imply would be this dope let's not
change Python Thanks
[Applause]
you